hi CNN we've missed you these last 5
months great to be back I'm here with
editor at large of reent magazine Matt
Welch and Senior editor for the dispatch
Sarah isgar okay Sarah which one of the
Trump indictments do you think is the
strongest oh there's so many to choose
from but it's a really easy question
it's the Florida case about the
classified documents and the obstruction
side you'll notice Trump and his allies
never talk about that one the other
cases are all much weaker in a variety
of ways but that Florida case so this is
the one where we took classified
documents and put them by the toilet
yeah
yeah why is that why is that such a
strong case uh it's after he's president
um there's just no real legal defense to
you know even if you're really
constipated needing those documents by
your
[Applause]
toilet
but I I know what they're going to say
which is Biden did the same thing he had
papers by his Corvette he didn't defy
subpoena lie about I know that I'm just
say he's not charged with having the
documents or taking the documents he's
charged with not giving the documents
back when the government was like knock
knock we have our documents back what
documents and see this is what I mean
when I always say he's stupid and
crazy
there's they're stupid like I think
Frederick Douglas is still
alive the stealth bomber is literally
invisible you know Healthcare is no one
knew it was complicated those are stupid
crazy is this it's just crazy it's just
a crazy unforced error why do it he
wasn't even looking at them he it just
was the mine
yeah that's and then when they came and
asked for the documents and he said no
and then they tried to move the
documents then he realized that was on
camera and so then he told the guy to
flood the server I mean it was like like
every step okay uh Nikki heli Rose in
the polls this week oh good for
you N9 to 10% nailing
it is that what it is are there enough
aalishan voters in the Republican party
for heard to become a serious re Revival
Revival to Trump Revival Ral rival oh
okay well we're doing this on the Fly
you know rival to Trump yes oh hell
no no there's a there's actually a
really interesting poll I I recommend
people look at the people at Fair vote
um who do rank Choice voting they had a
uh a poll that basically did ranked
Choice with the candidates a national
poll and so each time around you kick
someone off the island and then see how
it it goes until you get to only two
left and Donald Trump got like 47% or
something in the first vote first round
and then you know Doug berham goes and
Mike Pence goes bahah he doesn't go up
even a little bit turns out 47% of of
Republicans really want Donald Trump to
be the president and he was also number
13 by the most people like he was last
place like please anybody but Donald
Trump he only like gets over the
majority when everybody else is wiped
out Nikki Haley does very well in that
poll she comes in second once you start
knocking off Chris Christies and all
these semi- establishment people she
will she has the ability maybe to look
to get some people who want to vote for
Trump but the only way to get to the
Republican nomination is and this is why
Ron DeSantis still has a chance although
he's absolutely nose dived during this
calendar year is that people who like
Ronda santz also uh like Donald Trump
sometimes he can straddle that uh Nikki
Haley hasn't quite shown that and the
rest of them have no chance she has
really been across the the board though
I remember when the rumor was that they
were having an
affair remember that it was it was in
the first Trump book that remember that
I mean no I didn't never beli that
either but she's gone from that to I
wouldn't even have her on the ticket
look I worked for Carly furina in 2016
and we're seeing the exact same problem
that we saw then you can't have this
many candidates in the field that poll
which was fascinating actually showed in
the end that Ronda Sanz could beat
Donald Trump by three points if it were
only the two of them in the race right
well okay so was anyone surprised that
Donald
Trump boy no it's hard
[Music]
to
question wait a second leaked Intel oh I
read this on our nuclear submarine
program to an Australian businessman you
know what I I'm the last guy to defend
Trump this sounds like BS to me I mean
he he of course he's does a million
things that you shouldn't do but leaked
Intel our nuclear submarine program I
doubt if he knows the first thing about
our nuclear
and I I you know I don't think he gave
away technical Secrets he was just
bragging you know our submarines and I'm
kind of glad that it gets around the
world that we can kick your
ass this is the problem where you think
Trump is like evil and stupid like it's
kind of one of the other like he's an
gen not yours I'm just saying other
people like you can't believe he's like
the Super Genius who knows everything
about our nuclear subs but also a
who like doesn't know like where right
are like it can't be both right
okay all right uh what is
the what does the panel think of go
California governor Nome repealing the
law that banned doc banned doctors from
sharing unapproved Co information well
of course I love it they should have
never done in the first
place doctors should be able to speak
freely the media should be the Watchdog
of what's going on in the government not
the megaphone not the amplifier of it I
can't believe you brought up this case
because I'm really obsessed with this
idea that nuum and disantis are actually
you know different sides of the same
coin when it comes to civil liberties
like free speech right Newsome is
Banning doctors from saying something
about coid that he doesn't personally
believe to well now he's not okay well
cordin joined him first so you know okay
uh and at the same time you know Dan
santis down in Florida is telling
teachers that they can't you know teach
certain things at universities like how
about just the first amendment I'm Pro
that I also say
that Gavin Nome wanting to run for
president is the best thing that can
happen to
Californians uh cuz he'll make a better
Governor that way I say the same thing
yeah I think he's a great politician
I've been trying to get him to run for
president 15 years it would force him to
go to the center like this kind of stuff
and that brief I mentioned at the
Supreme Court where he now wants to like
have a different homeless policy like
he's moving to the center on all sorts
of stuff and he can win you you know
what it doesn't hurt to have a dreamy
candidate I'm not it really doesn't I'm
sorry I don't know that bare skin rug
photo like really weirds me out the what
the the what photo the photo with um him
Kimberly guilfoil where he's like on the
bare skin rug and it's like really I
don't know not my type what can I say
all
right should the Senate have loosened
the dress code to allow for John fedman
shorts and casual attire
no
this that I mean that was so
ridiculous I mean again what is this
with John Federman come on man if you
haven't seen it he looks like Kevin
Smith remember Kevin's the hockey shirt
shorts in the Senate I mean what is it
what point is this making what is the
point of this I I never got it I uh I'm
so torn between my hatred of rules and
institutions
and my hatred of inappropriate or people
who dress like me on weekends being in
the Senate that's bad we don't want we
don't want people who look like I just
feel I was such a stunt it's like oh I'm
I'm the man of the people but you know
what you know what the people actually
have to do dress yeah for work yeah
dress for work all right is some of that
luxury good stuff this idea that you're
a man of the people he comes from an
incredibly privileged background he's
never like been faced with being fired
for not wearing something right to work
and then you know that's what you get
the people who are always going on about
privilege always have the privilege to
be impractical in every possible way but
we got to go thank you CNN we'll see you
next
week